This is a villa bought by Russian President Vladimir Putin in Marbella,
Spain, worth $55 million.
President Putin's Spanish home
is just a 40 minute drive to the newly refurbished Malaga airport,
which now offers direct flights to Moscow.
The extravagant residential estate has a plot of land
totally more than 18,000 square meters
and is 400 meters above sea level
and less than eight miles from the Costa beaches.
His giant house has about 10 bedrooms,
its own helipad,
a veritable sunken swimming pool and a 10 car garage.
It has a formal piano bar and a wood framed library.
There's also a gym and cinema and a private champagne bar.
Vladimir Putin is the current president of Russia
and chairman of the State Council.
He is considered by the outside world
to be the de facto supreme Leader of Russia.
Since 2000,
he has been selected into the Forbes World's most influential people
many times.